live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships the phone number is8
825 5225
88255 225 I'm Ken Coleman joined by my
colleague and dear friend Jade warshaw
and we are here for you this hour it's a
free phone call America and so we want
to help you some of you are very new we
uh we see this in the data we see this
in the
reports every day and uh we know that
we've got some some language that maybe
you're not used to the baby steps uh so
we're going to get into that later this
hour that's going to be a lot of fun
just a basic breakdown uh to bring a lot
of you into the conversation because
this process absolutely works and we
want you to understand it so let's get
to the phones we start off with an and
Sacramento Ann how can we
help Hi how are you guys doing great how
are you good um my so my basic question
is my husband and I have recently
decided to get very intentional with
getting out of debt they were current me
baby St two I'm very familiar with this
steps I used it prior to us getting
married um to get out of my student loan
debt so I'm very familiar with the
intensity and everything um so five
years later would not be super
intentional with our budgets we start to
get on the same page um but my question
is I wanted to do FPU he wasn't open to
it didn't think that I would be for him
I even asked for it for my birthday
present um and then he recently decided
okay let's try it and last night was
supposed to be our first class but
unfortunately the coordinator didn't
show up it was the virtual class so now
he's kind of put off on it um and
doesn't want to do it any anymore and I
was super hopeful and in in that it
would teach us both the baby STS
together versus me just teaching it yeah
um and so I'm just wondering do I keep
trying to push to do FPU even though
it's now a topic of contention or just
focus on you know okay let's just focus
on our budget and getting more gazelle
intent um trying to get out of baby St
too look uh I man I hate that that
happened something must have there must
have been some extren exena
circumstances with that but I would keep
trying because what you said I agree
with as long as you're the one teaching
him and it's kind of like if he's
viewing that as you even if you're not
intending to but if he's viewing that as
you kind of like this is what we have to
do and here's the steps and here's like
he it sounds like his personality is not
feeling that so I would keep pushing to
have you know Dave and the other
personalities be the bad guy in that
case and let the let us teach it to you
um so I would follow up and find out
what happened with that but I would
definitely keep trying for it because
here's at at the end of the day here's
what happens when a couple is trying to
get on board get both spouses on board
you start kind of if one spouse doesn't
want to do it you start compromising and
when you start
compromising it it doesn't go the way
you want cuz in our minds we think oh
we're compromising like that's a good
thing but it's not because what happen s
is you start just being is and when
you're ising yeah right you're you're
not doing it full force and before you
know it you've looked up and it's been 5
years and you still haven't really made
any Headway and not only are you tired
and you're frustrated he gets the right
to be like see this thing that we tried
didn't work right because you did it
kind of halfway and you never saw
anything go through with it so I would
push to say like we're doing this or
we're not doing like like we're going
ham on this because here's the thing if
he says no the ish is going to get hit
the fan anyway right because you're
going to keep living out of control and
pretty soon something great happens when
your back is against the wall and the
other walls are closing in you realize
you do have to make a change so I hate
for it to get to that point but at the
same time sometimes when you split the
difference on this it becomes do you see
what I'm saying it actually backfires on
you in the long run so I would push to
get on the same page and that is in this
case him jumping over to your page not
you you know ripping a page out of your
book and him ripping a page out of his
book does that make
sense yeah yeah and so he's definitely
on the same page about getting out of
debt like I just started a second job
and he's currently looking um something
that can also work with his current work
schedule so we're definitely on the same
page about being more intense but you
know I want to go after that like I want
to be on the same page with our three to
six months I want to be on the same page
with you know all the basically all the
baby steps um so that's what I was
hoping FPU would be for yeah um uh but
now like he's like we need to get a
refund call to get a refund and so like
so now I have to like no I agree with
you all that that's a cop out that's a
cop out I don't think he wants to be on
the same page with you I'm not
something's not adding up but I'm not
saying that you're that you're not
telling us the truth I'm not sure you're
getting the whole story because he
either wants to be on the same page or
theory he doesn't and so if he wants to
be on the same page with you and he
wants to get out of debt then you're
going this is a great plan whether or
not our coordinator and whatever
happened there we'll get to the bottom
of that in fact Austin let's make sure
we get customer service involved with
this with an to make sure we get to the
bottom of what happened uh because we
want to serve you well uh there but he's
he's using this as a copout and and so
this is time for very serious talk and
you have to this is a marriage
conversation not a financial
conversation and and and I'm just going
to call it and and he and by the way
show him this I don't
care cuz dude let me tell tell you
something if your wife says that she's
stressed out by this money situation she
wants this she doesn't feel safe
whatever's going on and you're saying
yes I'm in and and you're using this uh
snafu or whatever happened last night as
a I want my money back and I'm out you
were looking for any excuse possible and
I would dare say my friend you are
manipulating her because you really
don't want to go all in and and Jade
already discussed the the negatives of
the isue
uh but I I I just think an this is you
saying to him I need you to do this for
me I want you to do this um it's it's a
marriage conversation Jade I I this guy
is uh he's not Allin he's not on the
same page no he's not Allin you know
it's interesting this whole thing of I
feel like we find that a lot Ken where
it's two spouses and one is like I'm
totally on board and the other one is
like I'm not and the call we get so much
is how do I get my spouse on board and
there it's always hit a point of they've
said you know we've compromised and
we've tried to work together on this and
you know he he or she doesn't want to go
all in and so we've just done the best
we can but you know you look up 5 years
later and you've still just made no
Headway in some ways you've gone further
into debt and I love what you said it's
a cop out and in some ways compromising
is a good thing but in other ways
compromising is a cop out because you
end up with you know one black shoe and
one brown shoe and you're look like a
fool in the end and you're tired and
you're worn out because you didn't do
the plan as written and the plan works
as written it doesn't work when you do
these various versions of it that you
just pulled out of your you know what
well I think what's going on here is is
that I think he absolutely does want to
be debt free but he does not want to do
what it takes to be debt now there's a
very big difference uh we can love the
idea of a better future but not love the
idea of doing what it takes to get said
better future that's the difference
that's the that's the bridge between
someone who is in any area of their life
uh not happy with where they are um at
some point you got to go you know what
if I want it that bad then I want to do
what it takes he's not there yet
unfortunately may take a little bit more
pain and frustration to get him there
but an we're on your team hang on the
line an we're going to figure out what
happened if there was anything going on
with our coordinator and we can make uh
make good on our promise uh but no don't
get the money back make him show up for
the class this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi re ref
finances defaulted private student loans
that other places won't touch and gives
you a custom loan built for you based on
your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show where we
talk with you about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw with me this hour 8825
8825 5225 Matt joins us now in Bristol
Tennessee Matt how can we
help hey thanks for having me how are
you guys great what's going going on
awesome I just wanted to first uh thank
you guys for everything you guys already
do I always joke with everyone saying
that I was raised by three parents my
mom my dad and Dave Ramsey and they just
instilled that at me in a young age and
just want to thank you guys for
everything y'all do and and just the
information you guys gave out but uh
don't want to hold too much of your time
just wanted to ask a quick question um
I've been out of school for about a year
year and a half now um I currently live
in an apartment and my lease is up in
May I've been lived here about 3 years
years and absolutely love it um but I do
have a uh I did make the decision to get
a German shepherd and space is a little
bit small um it's funny because actually
we actually made a trip down there in
March and visited the Ramsey Show and
went to cook bille and got him and he's
he's the best thing he's he's awesome I
love them but uh obviously that's a
that's a big demand of having a backyard
and one day I want to be able to uh get
one but just doing it the right way um
and like I said my lead ends in May and
just kind of want to take the steps of
eventually going to to getting a
house I love that um so let's find out
if you're even close so I'm assuming
you're debt free based on what you said
about all the Dave Ramsey stuff do you
have three to six months of of expenses
saved I do yes ma'am I um I went to uh I
went to school graduated um after about
eight years graduated last uh last May
and have just been working and doing as
much overtime as I can and finally have
all debt paid off and um have all about
a 3 to six month um Savings Plan set up
just in case of emergencies and just
kind of want to I just I just don't want
to go in because I know that that now is
a good time to buy one because it's not
really going to get better but then
again too I don't want to go overboard
and well the best time to buy a house is
when you can afford it right so kind of
scrap that out of your mind of of is the
market telling us it's a good time or is
the market telling us it's a bad time
the best time and a great time to buy a
house no matter what the market says is
when you can afford it and you can put
the right down payment down and all of
that so let's put that in our brains um
so you've got do you have three months
or six months of expenses because it's
just you right yeah it's me I I have I
have six months great excellent um so
what do you have saved in way of a down
payment have you done any research to
kind of find out what that down payment
should be well I mean I don't want to do
anything below 20% that's kind of where
I'm at and I think I'd be able to get
that um by that time frame um I've been
living on a budget pretty consistently
the past about four months
and have gone over it but I mean have
been able to adjust and not make not
make uh purchases that I shouldn't and
um just want to kind of gauge on on when
that should be show I mean I don't I
feel comfortable living another year
here um I I love where I'm at and I
think that I'd even be able to put an
even much bigger down payment and and
maybe even get a little bit more but I
love that I just want to go about it the
right way yeah yeah so the first thing
is doing your research to find out okay
what am I looking at what do those what
if is what I'm looking at can I afford
that and so it sounds like you've done
that you want to put 20% or more I think
that's great you know our guidelines are
somewhere between 5 and 20% the 20%
obviously you are avoiding private
mortgage insurance which is great and if
you're able to do up and beyond that I
think that's excellent however um I
would not necessarily let that keep you
because it's going to be a moving Target
the way the market is like everything's
always going to go up so you trying to
be like Oh I'm going to get to 40% like
that could be an Ever moving Target so
once you get to like I'm pulling the
trigger as once I get to to 20 um that's
kind of the way I am um with this Market
I mean if you wanted to wait it out you
could but my point is does that make
sense what I'm saying is that that
Target could move again by the time you
get that extra 10% saved to where your
10% has now gone back that's what I've
been thinking about yeah yeah that's
what I've been thinking about where I
save up and then the insurance rates go
up and up and up and it's almost as if
I'm just kind of playing catch up when I
mean I'm not in any rush or anything I
that's not something smart to do is in a
rush with finances that's right um but I
mean it would be it would be ideal to to
be in a house about a year year and a
half or so excellent and then of course
as long as you're looking at 15year
fixed rate mortgages have you looked
into that you're not looking at 30 years
right right I am yeah I'm looking at 15
years it's just a matter of being able
to find something I'd be comfortable in
um without having to do I mean 50 to 60%
of my income I mean I
mean no no more than 25% of your
take-home pays what you're aiming for
and that your take-home pay is um you
don't have to worry about what it well
you shouldn't be what what do I want to
say if you're investing if you've
already started investing 15% it would
be what it is before your investment
dollars right so it's 15% of that money
then your 15% is going away like that's
what we're looking at it doesn't have to
be like 15% of your you know pre-tax
after in like after investment after
insurance we're not looking at that it's
just your take-home dollars 25% does
that make
right yeah it's just it's one of those
things where it's almost as if I get on
Zillow every night and just calculate
stuff out um and I'm sure a lot of
people do that too but it's just one of
those things where I'll calculate it out
and I'm like well that that that
mortgage payment is going to be I mean
30% of my income but if I wait a year
and a half it could be 25 or I mean I
may that a little bit but it's like 50
or 40 to 50 now and then um I mean being
able to afford it just based on the down
payment but with how the market it's
moving I just wanted to kind of give
well let let me ask you about that then
and and Ken can take the ball from here
but your income is what it is now what
do you see it doing in the next one to
three years one to five
years it would most likely stay about
the same if not a little bit more but
not too
much yeah then you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't creep much above that 25% it
would be different if you're like yeah
I'm getting a certification and that's
going to cause my income to rise and if
you're like hey some of these are
looking up to 28 29 that's a little bit
different but I would not creep past
much much more past 25 if you don't see
a a path to increasing your income
anytime soon okay yeah I Matt I I think
you're itching for this house more than
you're letting on you keep coming back
to it and I'm just going to speak truth
to you as an older brother you need to
stay off Zillow because the more you're
on Zillow the more you you know let me
just tell you basic psychology here is
we act on what we focus on and we're
looking at Zillow all the time the itch
just keeps getting itchier and itchier
and you just want to scratch it and I'd
stay off Zillow I would stack up cash
it's just you and the dog
right yes it is dude I I I I don't want
you going 25% I I think you need to
relax I think you need to be like it's
just me and the
dog and and and and you're fine and and
I would save up more money I I wouldn't
be in any hurry I'm if you want to go
for a year and a half bust it go make
some side income if your income is
somewhat limited you have the ability to
do that but the more you're on Zillow uh
the more this becomes something you feel
like I've got to fulfill and I'm not
fulfilling this desire and you're single
with a dog and I wouldn't be in a rush
to get a house I just wouldn't more
money you could save the better because
um you know you're not you're not in a
rush right now to where you have to get
a house as Jade said so I I I would just
relax a little bit I can hear it in your
voice like oh I got to do it I got to be
a grownup I got to be responsible I got
to get a house and and you know we don't
know what your life's going to be like a
year and a half from now let's say you
got that money that you want for that
down payment a year and a half from now
and let's say that somebody else a
significant other potential mate a life
partner comes along all now now
everything is we start at at Ground Zero
in my mind because I'm not going to buy
a house like I would never buy a house
if I knew that I wanted to settle down
with somebody until I found that said
somebody that's me really 100% that is
uh controvers no it isn't it's just my
opinion but you don't know I'm not
telling everybody else to do that but
I'm say I get it but it's uh it's
interesting because there's a lot of
unknowns there right but I'd rather have
I'd rather not be locked into a mortgage
I'd rather be stacking cash living on
less than you know than I need to make
and and and and look wait a minute K cuz
I'm walking down this road now fine
let's let's run down the road you wake
up 5 years from now no this is good this
is good I started it trust me cuz you
wake up 5 years from now and uh Mrs
Wright still hadn't come around the
corner are you still waiting to buy a
house even if you've got the money maybe
not but at right now but but we're not
talking 5 years we're talking now which
is exactly why I wouldn't buy the house
in a year if he's dating if he wants to
settle down I wouldn't buy right away
but that's that's not a principle it's
not a principal it's not a ramsy
principal I'm espousing I'm saying me
personally I'm just this this rush to
buy it's it's it's dangerous and cash is
good it gives me options renting's good
when I'm playing the field you know what
I'm saying this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is with me and we
are here for you
8825 5225 that's 8825 5 225 let's go to
Nate who is now joining us in Salt Lake
City Utah Nate how can we
help hello my friends uh my wife and I
we started our journey with Dave Ramsey
about 12 years ago and and and it's been
a wonderful thing let me tell you we we
love Dave and we love listening to your
show um we made it all the way through
baby step three we had three to six
months in expenses saved up and then
it's been a little bit of a rough year m
a couple of months ago I lost my job
also got some medical bills oh thank you
for that we've also got some medical
bills that stacked up and so we are back
on baby step number two at this point um
and we're looking for a little bit of
advice on on how to how to navigate
these next couple of months as I'm as
I'm on the job hunt are you bringing in
any income at all right now or are you
still on do you have I have a little bit
of residual from from my previous
employment a couple of months um of of
money they set me up with okay um just
to help with that transition okay um you
know our company was bought out and I
was downsized and they took care of me
but it's not going to last forever sure
how just so we can walk through this how
much more uh time do you have with that
paycheck coming in uh about three months
you got three more months before that
goes away and is it the same amount of
money you were making
before yes sir okay good all right so
what specifically are you thinking about
what are you guys wondering
about well we've got like I mentioned
some bills about 2500 in medical bills
and then you know just as we were making
decisions to keep the lights on and
things as as we were dealing with this
rough year um we also ended up not
paying our tithing to our church for a
few months and so we we'd like to make
up that difference which is about $2,500
there too oh I love your heart so
$5,000 what is $5,000 if I sent you a
check for $5,000 which by the way I'm
not going to but if I did what would
that do for you mentally and emot
in in light of this
call well you know that that would take
a lot of weight off but um the the
discussion my wife and I are having is
do we do we take this this residual
income I've got and do we stuff it into
our baby step which you know got got
dropped back down to $1,000 do we do we
build that up or do we work on our debt
snowball while I'm doing this job hunt
so is the only two debts the 2500 in
tithe that you're considering a debt and
the 2500 in medical or is there other
debt
well we we've also got our mortgage but
you know that's less than 25% of our
income but those are the only two
because you know we've been working the
system for a while yeah and we'll put
the mortgage off we'll leave it for a
baby step six where it belongs um why
don't you work and go make $5,000 while
you're searching yeah why don't you just
go get a j o doesn't have to be in the
same career field but why don't you just
go while you're while you're connecting
networking uh applying why not go make
five
,000 uh on the side I'm going to call it
on the side you're still getting your
Severance and and and get the 5,000 that
you want to pay the tithe and the and
the the 2500 for tithe and 2500 for
medical and then be be all good why not
do that oh I'm absolutely open to that
now we' we've got a little uh
10-month-old at home so as soon as I go
find a job it's got to fit in around
either daycare or my wife's or my wife's
schedule she works too she's a
teacher so I'm I'm absolutely open to
that I've been looking um I've called in
on a couple of you know temporary
opportunities but haven't found anything
that's that fits in with with that
lifestyle wait wait wait wait wait wait
what do you mean lifestyle you need a
full-time job anyway what does that need
to look like what's the schedule it it
means it means my full-time job's got to
pay at least um $2,000 a month to cover
that daycare so your wife's your wife's
income basically covers everything
except 2,000 bucks like that's what you
feel like at the very least you need to
be be able to make per month yep okay
are you watching the baby right now and
she's working is that what you mean yes
I am she's in the high chair in the
other room got you I see now that
explains because I'm telling you to go
get AJ o why don't you work
nights absolutely you know I'm I'm open
to that no no no no not open do it like
there there's a difference between I'm
open to it and get busy man go work
Walmart from 6 until midnight yeah
you'll make 2,000 a
month while searching for the the
full-time job brother I'm trying to save
you some money now you can do it your
way but my way is better cuz you get to
keep that Severance money for living
expenses go make $5,000 on the weekend
listen you're 10-month-old does not have
a concept of time uhhuh I'd be working
Saturdays I'd be doing whatever to come
up with $5,000 to remove this weight you
use the word weight yeah the baby
doesn't know when you're there and they
don't know they're not going to remember
that it's like you're a bad father Nate
you're you're you're in storm mode right
now and so I know that you have these
debts sitting here that you're like man
if I could just get this money I could
pay them off until you get something
stable where you're bringing in the
right amount of income to supplement
your wife's income so that you guys can
keep your life going you know these are
these are Bare Necessities we're talking
about daycare and things like that right
so I would take the severance money and
I'd hang it back and put it with your
emergency funds right now because if you
don't get out there like Ken said and
make money do you want to know what's
going to happen you're not going to have
enough money to cover your basic bills
next month so I would not push ahead
trying to do these baby steps because
you don't have enough money coming in to
cover your bills so like Ken said you've
got to get out there and you've got to
get any job that will take you while
you're on the search for you know
whatever that ideal job or dream job is
MHM and you want to know what let's
let's let's talk about this from a
little bit of emotional standpoint
because there is something to be said
like you said you've been listening for
12 years you got so far down the path
with the baby steps and then this thing
just kind of blew you backwards and it's
like oh man like we're failures and it
feels like that but you're absolutely
not the the the moral of the story here
is the big bad wolf huffed and puffed
but he didn't blow your house down
because you did have those things in
place and you're not deeply you're not
back deeply in debt you got you're
you're trying to pay back tithes for ch
out loud you know what I'm saying like
it's not like you've just been blown to
Smither and I think you've just got to
forgive yourself and go look we did
everything right we had 3 to six months
of expenses in place and I lost my job
and that money was there when we needed
it and now we're just building it back
up right right you know so I love it
don't don't get down on yourself just
get out there and you know it's it's
about what you do next right now yeah I
I agree and I wouldn't feel the pressure
to pay all 2500 and tithe back right
away you know just just manage the
situation be a good Steward of of what
you have right now and I think that's
the key um really interesting you know
um again I I see a pattern here and
again love Nate but you know this idea
of I'm open to it I'm open to it well I
mean you know I got to tell you
something um if you want to change your
life you have to grab it by the neck and
wrestle it down I'm thinking of I mean
I'm thinking of the U GE I'm going to
upset some of the animal rights
activists uh but you know watch those
rodeos every once in a while on ESPN and
they hop off and they grab the the
little calf and they wrestle it down to
the ground that's the idea like it's
some point you know waiting for change
to just fit beautifully into the
existing schedule we have will get you
in a situation where you wake up 5 10 15
years down the line going man I never
made that change where'd the time go I
mean get after it yeah get after it you
know you you bring up an interesting
point I've I've been reading this book
about um
negotiating and in the book he says when
people say yes or you're right you're
right you're right yes yes the the the
chances of them actually implementing
that change is almost nothing really the
phrase that you're looking for them to
say is that's right when they say that's
right that means they understand what's
going on and they understand uh how
they've been thinking and they see that
you understand it too and when you hear
the phrase that's right
that's when you know there's a change
that's about to implement and the whole
time he kind of was like yeah yeah yeah
you're right Ken you're right you know
what I mean and it's kind of funny
because now when I hear that I'm like I
don't know if they're going to do it so
Nate I hope you get to the point of
saying you know what that's right that's
right I do need to get out there I do
need to get a job I'm not we're not
failures we just hit a rough patch yep
and uh yeah that's right all right so
I've got something for you Nate hang on
the line we're going to give you the get
clear work assessment just to give you
some extra Clarity and affirmation on
the type of work that you were designed
to do and then the book from paycheck to
purpose which is the guide to the next
gig for you hang on the line we
appreciate the call Nate so happy for
you in that 10-month-old but get busy my
man let's take advantage of that
Severance not just use it this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation a one thing that has helped
me with the daily practice of meditation
in prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's three months free to prioritize
your mental health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music prayers meditation and more and
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition if you don't have a faith
tradition this is a great place to learn
more more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember palow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is alongside 8825
5225 882 25
5225 hey we have a lot of folks uh that
are joining in on this conversation on
all the different platforms podcast
YouTube of course radio sirusxm and uh
and if you're new to all this and you're
kind of wondering where do you sit in
this journey these seven baby steps uh
you just want to get caught up we've got
a great resource for you at ramsy
solutions.com called get started just go
to the main website ramsy solutions.com
click on get get started and it's just a
uh just a couple of minutes and it will
allow you to see where you are in the
baby steps get you caught up so that you
can truly get started to changing your
life also uh if you are enjoying the
program would you subscribe uh leave a
great review and share that all helps us
spread the good newsle 8825 5225 Caleb
is up in Seattle Washington Caleb how
can we
help hi folks thanks for taking my Paul
how are you guys great what's going
on um so uh just short and sweet I have
about $50,000 in my savings account and
uh roughly
134,000 in a couple of debts and I'm
just wondering if I should pull that
trigger and and pay that debt and uh
after the fact how am I wanting to
invest this savings uh towards like a
future purchase or retirement just kind
of confused doing all the research
myself has been really stressful yeah
well the answer is the answer is yes you
should do that and now Jade's going to
tell you what you do after that yeah so
where's that money sitting now that
50,000 uh it's currently in a highin
savings account getting about 4%
interest great yeah that's just where it
should be and I would pull out the 13 or
14,000 and I would pay off this debt and
then assuming uh I don't know what your
uh month toon expenses are but I'd like
for you to keep whatever is remaining at
least for 3 to 6 months of expenses is
it just you or are you
married um I'm currently single but I
live with my mother um so we we share
the bills together um we currently rent
our home um and I recently just took
over expenses from my grandmother who
kind of moved to a different home so I'm
taking over the rent the power bill all
of that um so I think my monthly
expenses are roughly 2500 a month and I
bring in just over 5,000 okay uh so I
would set aside whatever 3 to six months
of expenses for you um your single
single guy I know you're living with
your mother but you're single and at
some point you're going to Branch out so
three is fine but if you when you
whenever you go to Branch out which
we're going to get to in a minute i'
bump it up to six um and then whatever
is left are you doing baby step four are
you investing 15% of your income at
all uh yes currently that's um 15% of my
paycheck goes towards a retirement
account okay great company provided so
now we can get back to the other
question how long is this living
situation with your mom GNA be cuz it's
not going to be
long right um I I wish I wish I had a
definitive answer um she we're mainly
here for the sake of stability she's
going through stage four kidney failure
um so just a stable home with with we
know our expenses um we we've known this
landlord for 20 years I've lived in this
house for maybe 15 um and we know him so
he keeps our rent low just for the sake
of being helpful being a good Christian
man okay so I I would say maybe a couple
of years at at Max um you know I do have
a girlfriend I I haven't considered
popping the question um and I haven't
you know thought about making that step
I'm I'm almost 25 so still you're just
taking care of your mom right
now right yeah so I think that I I think
going off the so let's give you some
action steps getting off the phone today
number one is the first thing you're
doing is you're paying off that debt and
then what you're doing is the money that
is left I want to kind of divide this in
in in two separate areas um I love by
the way this is not an ad or anything
like that but I use al.com for my um
hysa and I like it because they've got
these different buckets and so you could
say okay I'm going to put my 3 to six
months in one bucket over here right and
in whatever Bank you have you do do
whatever you want but the idea is I've
got this money set aside for my 3 to six
months over here and I know exactly what
that amount is and I know that I'm not
touching it unless there's an emergency
and then whatever's left
I want you creating a three a baby step
3B which is you just putting aside money
cuz eventually you are going to want to
buy a house and eventually you are going
to want to you know maybe you marry this
girl maybe you don't but uh with any
extra money I want you being intentional
about putting money towards a down
payment as well with anything extra that
you have um coming into your monthly
budget and even whatever is left out of
that savings after you've put away your
three to six
months okay sound like a plan three-step
plan
that's a great plan I I love it thank
you you break it down really really
simple makes a lot less stressful oh
good dude you're you're good hanging out
with your mom like this are you who's
taking care of her while you're
working um so I work from home currently
and uh or my mom is a part of a a state
program that sends caregivers out to
kind of look after her make sure she has
what she needs um and when they're not
here it's kind of I'm here to you know
get her get her something to eat or
something along the lines of that okay
that's great all right well you're a
good man and so sorry that she's going
through that and sorry that you were
having to uh to see that and Pro provide
that role although I know you're more
than willing to as a loving son but
that's tough stuff so uh thank you for
the call let's go to Ethan now in Newark
New Jersey Ethan how can we
help hi um my name's Ethan I have around
$775,000 from inheritance and I just
want to know what I can do so I don't
blow it I have around like a few
thousand in my uh Roth ra and I'm making
around like
1.6 uh ,000 monthly CU that I'm a
waiter okay okay uh how did you inherit
the
money well it's actually a crazy story
so my
dad's Aunt I guess you could say so my
great aunt she was not fond of the
family and she didn't leave the money to
anyone so it ended up going to not that
family and uh to all the
grandchildren wow oh so that's your
that's your share of what all the
grandchildren
got yes okay good for you cool cool cool
and did you tell us you're you're making
$1600 a month did I understand that
correctly yeah just roughly it it ranges
but yeah okay and that's for so you
mentioned you had a Roth IRA and then
you said I'm making $1600 a month being
a waiter
correct uh yeah um are you doing
anything at this point to like further
Ed
like what's that look like well so right
now I uh really I so I got this this
money around like the end of my senior
year so I wanted to take a gap year and
so that's what I'm doing right now I'm
planning to go uh next year to uh the
local community schools for a x-ray
technician job okay and
then overall though uh further education
besides that would be just like trying
to learn other ways to make money I
opened a website
um trying to figure that out but it's
still you know it's I'm just trying
right now yeah yeah no uh my screen says
what should I do with this money so I
don't blow it so I think that's uh
hilarious and I think that's a good way
to be thinking um my a1's in a A123 for
you would be somewhere along the lines
of this well first where are you living
what's your living
situation well of I'm 18 so I'm only I'm
just living with my parents right okay
you're still with your parents okay so
my my first thoughts on this would be
there's nothing that you need to do
that's of
major need right now like you said the
biggest thing is don't blow it so I'd
put it I'd probably drop it in a high
yield savings account for a moment
because you're going to need to pull out
this money when it comes time for you to
get your X-ray tech education right how
much does that cost it's actually not
that expensive because it's through a
community college and they have a good
Apprentice program so it would be no
more than $6,000 okay
$6,000 and then you're going to want at
some point you are going to move out and
when that happens you're going to want 3
to six months of expenses when you move
out and you're going to need like first
and last month's rent and all of that so
I kind of would love for you to do some
research on what that's going to look
like because my guess is you're 18 and
at least in a year or maybe a year and a
half you're going to be moving out on
your own so let's start looking at what
that might cost and what that might look
like and then we're setting that money
aside and you're going to talk to your
parents and you're going to say look I
really need
accountability do not let me blow this
money I'm not buying a new car all right
I'm not you're not going to find me in
the club like 50 Cent right you're not
doing any of that you're going to sit on
this it's going to make money for you in
that hysa until it's there when you need
it good stuff I'm not sure Ethan knows
who 50 Cent is you could find me in the
club yeah everybody knows that I don't
know all right this is the ramsy show
[Music]
n
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in life
specifically with your money and your
relationships and in your work thrilled
to have you with us I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joining joins me the phone
number to jump in is 8825 5225 that's
[Music]
88255 225 let's get it started this hour
with Kendra who is in Denver Kendra how
can we
help Hi how are you good Kendra what's
going
on um I just got married about a month
ago that's exciting way to
go thank you um we combined all of our
finances and we had a plan to pay for
the wedding and that plan did not go
accordingly so we ended up going into a
bit of debt on top of some pre-existing
debt so now we're just kind of looking
for advice as newly WS to what happened
off right and get out of this what
happened um we were living with fam so
we were able to set the money aside we
weren't really paying rent and that plan
faded
and we ended up moving out and getting
into a house which of course in Denver
the rent is
skyrocketing wait y'all went y'all up
and bought a
house uh we actually rent a house oh
rent a house okay okay yeah so how much
that kind of took our wedding budget
away from us but we weren't really
willing to compromise on the wedding
which was not a good financial decision
by any means so we went into debt oh how
much money did you Lo did you get take a
loan out for this wedding we took about
32,000 well
$32,000 for a
wedding yeah please tell me it's not on
like credit cards how did you pay for it
we did we started with credit cards and
I did have some savings so we paid for
part of it as we went but uh 32,000 is
actually on personal loan wow what did
you spend that on I'm just curious cuz
I've been marri a long time and I had no
idea weddings I know that they can be
outrageous but what did you spend that
money on I got to
know uh the venue by itself was about
7500 and that's no service or anything
just the building basically okay um
photographers videographers football
everything I wondered if you just rented
a shrimp boat to bring the shrimp in for
the reception it was so expensive my
gosh so you had you had some money you
had some money that you cash with and
this is the 32,000 wasn't the overall
cost of the wedding that was the overage
that you went into debt for
correct so Ian I think our wedding was
budgeted at right about 35 total so you
didn't spend any of your real money
credit card debt well we had some
pre-existing credit card debt so we were
paying for stuff kind of as we went and
paying that off as we booked vendors but
okay so much for the uh so much for the
honeymoon period oh gosh cuz now you all
going to have to bust it to pay this off
um yeah no kidding yeah okay there's a
big red flag here for me like there's
something that's glaringly like like
glaring its red light and it's the fact
that early on you guys were hit with a a
fork in the road like do we lower do we
lower our budget and get what we can
afford or do we just say the heck with
it and you know put the pedal to the
metal and go into debt right um so I'm
worried because and and I'm worried too
that there was credit cards involved and
all this stuff so you guys have a a a
mental mind shift that must happen um do
you see what I'm saying that's the
bigger in our spending yeah so that's
that's almost a bigger deal for me in
this moment than the debt is you guys
looking at each other and going okay how
do we want to live our life from now on
like what type of people are we going to
be uh what type of adults are we going
to be when it comes to money are we
going and this is a conversation this is
the next date night are we going to be
the type of people that we see um a
vacation we want and we see a TV or a
car that we want and we go you know what
we can afford to just take out the
payments I mean we'll just pay it off
for or are you going to be the type of
people that go you know what from here
on out drawing a Line in the Sand we
don't borrow money and that's first and
foremost you guys both need to look at
each other and say are we going to be
the people who decide that we don't
borrow money anymore
yep we have had that talk and what's the
answer I think we're on the same page um
just think from like watching the videos
and stuff
online I just I got to tell you you
think you're on the same page on the
same page what she she is on the page
ready to jump into it oh I know you are
I think you're on the page I don't think
he's anywhere near the book M he's in a
MAG he's in a a magazine he's in a Truck
magazine where is he is that true he's
not that he's not that okay good good so
what's what's your so real quick what's
your combined what's the debt not just
the wedding the total debt and then what
are your combined
incomes yep so total debt I calculated
at about or just under 90 I think it's
like 88,000 okay and can you break down
the type of debt com sure um we have two
vehicle loans those are both about
16,000 each um I have student loans
which luckily is only about 8,000 could
much worse um and then credit cards
combined we have about 16,000 left and
then the personal loan for 32 on the
wedding who gave you that
money uh just like Sofi loan or
something I found okay personal loan I
misunderstood okay and what's your
combined
income right now I'm estimating about
130 has kind of VAR so so you guys can
do this but you got to get dramatic with
it you got to get real itic U so so you
called we what was your question for us
did we did we answer what you wanted us
to answer did you ask it what what what
can we do here really just kind of
looking for advice on where to start all
right so I'd start with the
cars do you have any equity in those
cars not really you're upside
down I don't think we're really upside
down but would' probably break even or
be slightly upside down like $1,000 or
two ,000 not anything
major you know so first first and
foremost debt snowball like Ken is Right
I'd be looking at these cars but first
we're listing them smallest to largest
so the the $88,000 student loan
technically is first in your snowball
however well actually that's not true
your credit cards what's the lowest I'm
I'm guessing it's not just one credit
card for 16,000 right yeah yeah there's
um one is about a $10,000 balance but
then the rest of them are all pretty
small okay so we'll we'll list them
smallest to largest and knock out the
smallest ones first so that's that's the
overarching game plan of this and that's
how you're going to feel motivated to
keep going so tonight you guys get off
the phone and go okay let's put these
things in order smallest to largest
that's thing one then next do you guys
have a budget are you on a budget at
all um I've kind of just like started
writing stuff down all right well we're
going to make sure that you have we're
going to make sure you have every dollar
which is the world's best bu in app on
the planet it's going to help you guys
get control you're both going to be able
to see it it's going to be on both of
your mobile devices on both of your
laptop computers so you can see it
you're going to be able to see your
money each day in real time what's going
on with your money so uh make sure that
Austin pick up to get you that and those
are the two keys find out what's going
on with your money and find as much
margin as possible so you can throw that
at the smallest debt and that's how you
work through this debt snowball you guys
can be clear of this in 12 in 24 months
James Jade I got to talk about a new
idea during the break should I spend it
it's calls about wedding budgets and I
I'm the
[Music]
judge well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show Jade
warshaw is alongside I'm Ken Coleman and
we are here for you America talking
about your money of course and then I
I'm the work uh personality here on the
Ramsey team and if you think about your
income related to work the environment
you're in the opportunity to grow so
that you can increase your income I'm
the guy to take any work related
questions as well so let's get those
inle
88255 225 Tula California is where
Jennifer is Jennifer how can we
help hi um thank you for taking my call
um I need some direction and guidance
because I'm feeling a little lost okay
um so I was in a car accident and
received a settlement check and it's
250,000 okay so I got into a trade
school to pay for my
education and I hated it um so I
withdrew from the program and now I'm
currently looking for a job um I just
feel lost uh
what was the
trade uh it was an LVN uh Program help
me out I'm not I'm drawing a blank um
nursing oh gotcha it was just really
accelerated and I wasn't grasping the
information with how quick the program
was gotcha now why did you choose
nursing I thought it was what I wanted
to do why um um I've always had a desire
to help people MH um you know when my
grandma was sick it was nice being able
to
help and um now I'm just feeling a
little discouraged I'm in my 30s I have
a son who's 14 um and I need to preserve
my settlement so I just I don't know
what direction to to well I'm gonna have
Jay jump in on that on what to do on the
settlement and and make sure we maximize
that but I'm curious on this this
nursing trade school had it not been so
accelerated
ated uh maybe different environment and
if you don't know the answer to this
that's okay but I want to dig on it do
you think that it would have been a
better experience had it been maybe not
so
accelerated yeah um I think um you know
after my accident I wasn't I'm not the
same um and accelerated is not for me y
so maybe something a little more
slower so that's that's the key because
here's what's going on you got a lot you
got a lot going on number one I know
yeah you had you had the accident
there's some challenges with that uh
then you you you identify this this
trade you know going in nursing I've
always loved serving being a
caregiver is that a fair description of
you
caregiver yeah yeah and so you you
identify this opportunity you get in it
and it's just overwhelming and you
you're going through a range of emotions
right now I suspect one is probably
frustration because you you had some
excitement about it the other is
probably probably a little bit of uh
discouragement as you said because maybe
you feel you're not good enough and I
don't think that's true so that's why
I'm locking in on this right now I I
don't know that you need to be uh
bewildered because I still think there's
a theme here it may not be nursing or it
may be nursing but it's a different
program I just don't want you to get
thrown off course because this was a
very difficult Challenge and you
couldn't meet the challenge I was never
good in school I was never a good test
Taker and and yet there's a lot of good
things I can do and a lot of good things
you can do so what about different
caregiving options what about other jobs
that are caregiving but they aren't as
nuanced as it relates to the training
maybe for being a nurse have you
considered that um I have um I think I'm
just trying to see what is out there you
know I'm trying to good kind of take
this opportunity to be like okay this is
a clean slate yes what else is out there
what else can I do but it's just it's so
overwhelming you know with a child and
what's overwhelming about that right now
talk to us
um I feel just the weight responsibility
on my shoulders yeah you know it's just
scary yeah do you have no income coming
in um no since I quit my job but I am
looking I'm actively looking because
that's priority number one okay
and then um that's what I want for you
so a couple things and I want I want to
bring Jade in on this the settlement and
make sure we don't spin this but let me
to that
end I just want you to get a decent job
where you can you're valued it's a safe
setting and you're making some decent
money and you're taking care of you and
your child and let's take the pressure
of picking this purposeful path off the
table for now yeah that's there I think
you're already on the right path but I
want you to just let's go let's let's
let's leverage every relationship you
have to get a good job with some decent
benefits and let's just breathe okay
coming out of the accident and
everything Jade's going to give you some
great advice on that now coming back off
of off of you know getting stable
getting the money invested I want you to
then begin to just because you've got a
job now you begin to look out there what
are the type of jobs that allow me to be
a caregiver I spend most of my day using
what you do best and you've got some
great compassion and empathy for people
probably just a tremendous Communicator
listener uh and you're going okay what
are other types of jobs that don't
require me to go into
nursing and let's just see what's out
there because what's intimidating
Jennifer is the fact that you just don't
you can't name for me right now two or
three other options but I could give you
one so could you work in a nursing home
nursing homes are always looking for
very good people to come in and help
probably make make some decent money
decent benefits that's just one option
doesn't have to be that okay but you
begin to identify there are multiple
paths that I can go and now all of a
sudden it's not so scary but I I want to
we're going to give you some resources
I'm going to give you my assessment to
get clear work assessment Jennifer you
promise me you'll take it yes I promise
great it's going to spit out some very
detailed information for you about you
give you a purpose statement and give
you some direction I'll give you my book
from paycheck to purpose That'll Walk
you down the path after the assessment
but Jade come in and let's talk about
this $250,000 she's got yeah so is
everybody fine after this accident uh
yes yes there's no ongoing like health
or anything like that health issues um a
surgery but um I'm okay now okay okay
and uh so let's get a let's get a quick
Financial snapshot do you guys have any
debt anything saved like what's it look
like um I save I'm a really good saver
um so 10,000 in my checking um I paid
off my car and credit cards so no so no
debt awesome cool and so what student
loans no student loans no debt of any
kind just 10,000 sitting in your
checking account yeah and you're calling
that like saved money it's not you know
it's not month-to Monon money okay no
cool um what's your living
situation um I rent a room okay um uh
which is 00
so and I'm guessing so your 13-year-old
son is not living with
you uh yes um is yes he is okay yes
so first things first is like Ken said
we've got to start looking for a job and
then as soon as you secure a job I want
you to start looking for a place to rent
that's not one room like a nice a
reasonable place for you and your son to
live okay okay and so you're going to
start doing that you're going to start
pricing that out and we're going to
choose something based on what we're
projecting our income to be once we land
somewhere right so this is going to
require you to do some research okay
because what I want you to do is I want
you to kind of walk through do your best
to walk through the baby steps and the
ones that you can't quite get to let's
at least plan for it right so um you
have no debt so let's put aside out of
that
250,000 plus the 10 ,000 let's put aside
what we think would be about 6 months of
expenses for you and your son if once
you get an apartment once you get stable
what you think that will look like and
we're going to put that in a high yield
savings account aside not don't keep it
in your checking account keep it
someplace else and then we're going to
get that job and we're going to start
looking once we get those benefits we're
investing 15% of our income and we're
going to start looking just be in the
market for what what it might look like
to buy a house one day start doing the
math and we're going to put some of that
money aside and then we're going to work
with the smart Vestor Pro on the rest of
this money um Al Austin will pick up and
help you get connected with the smart
Vester Pro because I want this money out
of sight out of mind gaining interest
for you so it's there for you when you
need it upon retirement good stuff we're
rooting for you you're going to get
there I promise Jennifer you're a brave
single Mama love the single moms out
there that're doing so much we're here
for you this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
coming to you from our worldwide
headquarters just south of Nashville
Tennessee I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw is with me this hour the phone
number to jump in is8
825-5222 hanging out in the lobby and we
invite you to come anytime you'd like to
watch the show and uh on the debt free
stage in the lobby next to the fabulous
uh audience that I was talking about uh
are Chris and Amanda welcome Chris and
Amanda how are you doing great where are
you guys from Rochester New York
Rochester New York all right did you see
the guy over there with the bills shirt
on that would be my father okay all
right good we got a member of the bills
Mafia in the lobby so that's always
exciting uh all right and uh
you guys are here because you paid off
some debt so tell us how much debt did
you pay off we paid off $
48,8 35 yeah wow and how long did that
take it took us 11 months oh wow getting
after it and tell us your range of
income during that time we started out
around
72,000 by the end of the journey we were
down we got up to 990,000 wait what did
you do to bump it to 90 a lot of
overtime what do you guys do I'm a m
Postal Service nice and I'm a stay-at
home mom so he's really been working so
hard for our
family so were you a stay-at-home mom
through the whole 11 months yeah Wow way
to go thank you that's something that is
something all right so what happened
what was it 11 months ago what happened
to make you guys get on this journey and
you to work so hard Chris well it all
started with a whole life policy I
actually was at work and I was loading
the truck up next to a coworker who I
had mentioned that I was leaving early
that day to go sign the paperwork for
the whole life insurance policy and uh
that's when his eyes lit up and went big
and said you got to stop doing that now
uhuh and you got to listen to this show
and read this book so and I was a little
you know n all right I'll give it a
chance so I listened to the show for a
couple weeks before I even mentioned it
to Amanda or anything and then uh once I
read The Total Money Makeover it was
game over and uh that's when I came home
to her yeah he came home and he's like
I've you know I've never made this much
money in my life this is the most I've
made and I'm hitting a wall I'm working
40 to 60 hours we don't see each other
like we can't I can't keep going on like
this we can't keep going on like this we
need to do something and we were like
taking out of our savings to pay for
bills and do things every month and we
were living paycheck to paycheck and it
just shouldn't have been that way so
working too hard to feel that broke
definitely yeah we just spending too
much money by the end of the month we we
had a nice savings we thought but uh we
were just draining it
every oh wow so every time you stack up
the money you were pulling it back out
for bills yeah we we got a tax return
and we kind of put that away into the
savings yeah and we that was going to be
our account to vacation and stuff yeah
but then uh it just went to every month
it was just too much and it so then when
Chris comes home and he's like hey I
have the solution for all of our
problems it's a guy on the radio what
was your reaction to that were you like
yes I'm on board say less I'm doing it
or are you like wait a second like what
are you talking about like who's telling
you that you know like of course I was
kind of like questioning and asking all
the questions and not like completely
you know I and then he brought the book
home and I didn't read it sorry but um I
hadn't read it but then like I you know
I didn't want to see him so frustrated
and like stressed out and I was feeling
it too and and so I was just like what
you know tell me more about it and let's
do this I'm on board I love that so what
kind of debt was this anyway there was
uh six credit cards and two cars two car
loans yeah six credit cards wow did you
sell the cars or did you pay them off no
we paid them off nice yeah I still got
the car okay very nice my parents were
like we want to help you let us like
we're alive right now we have the money
let us give you the money and I'm like
no I don't want to take money from you
and we actually had like gotten or like
transferred our balances over to like 0%
credit cards and we were going to start
doing it that way and pay off as much as
we could and everything and then we
found this and you realized all that was
just the runaround y now I heard you say
Chris that you were already working
crazy hours yeah when you came home with
all this did you did you add more hours
yes I did I was working probably 10
hours a day and then once Co hit over
time was unlimited wow there were so
many open spots so I was doing probably
12 hours a day wow 6 days a week wow so
what did you guys do once you got on
board did you just immediately start
slashing the budget did you sit down
create a budget what did that look like
it was the budget um we've never had one
I never had one growing up I don't know
you've never had one growing up I was
like budget I can do this in my head
like we don't need a budget budget what
yeah like no oh gosh so when when you
realize okay cuz obviously the Crux of
all this is the budget and once you
realize that was your what was your
reaction like cuz I know for me I used
to be like a budget come on no I don't
think so you know so what was your
reaction to that so it felt kind of
suffocating I'm more the free spirit um
and he's more the like okay we got to
save we got you know so it was kind of a
little suffocating at times but we just
communicate and we talk about everything
and you know it's we just keep open
communication and we the budget it
really opened up how how much we we were
spending on money you know spending
money on things we didn't need we were
going out a lot you know it's hard to
when you working a lot and it's hard to
want to be home make dinner so so what
do you say to people because I mean Ken
can attest to this all the time like
people are like you know I don't want to
be on a budget it's going to ruin my fun
it's going to you know take me out like
speak to that person who's got $48,000
of debt and they're fighting back uh
they're fighting the budget tell them so
I would say just you know Live Well that
you say it all the time live like no one
else you know it's hard at first and
your mind kind of just shifts when you
start to like get out of debt little by
little you like get excited about it and
then like the budget's not so hard and
you know you you we really focus on
what's the most important to us at the
time and we budget that money for that
and then I don't know we ate out a ton
so we slashed a lot of that out no more
coffee no Starbucks no anything like
that you're to tell about it yes still
here what was the most extreme thing you
did on cutting the food budget what did
you do rice and beans did you did uh we
did a lot of pasta yes pasta pizza
perogies all that sounds delicious three
like sound like you're suffering at all
no that sounds delicious we weren't
suffering I didn't say so you're not
sick of pasta we still eat it to this
day very good okay I like that all right
great now what about support system we
have a huge support system support
system they all came to join us today
all right tell us who all is here cuz
they're beaming with pride I know I got
we got my parents my brother Brendan
who's in a wheelchair okay then I got my
brother Shane uhhuh my father-in-law cos
wow my Aunt Nancy and my sister Kelly
fantastic behind here is uh my
mother-in-law who's taking care of our
baby right now so so fun so everybody
was supportive they weren't going you
guys have lost your mind they were
supportive no I mean that's great how
much of a difference does that make to
have somebody supporting you it's big to
have somebody cheering you on yeah it's
hard to do it by yourself yeah wow guys
so what's it feel like now feels great
amazing I could cry I know it feels
awesome being here and yeah being able
to celebrate with our family and it's
amazing that everybody could get off of
work or take the time off and it really
means a lot to us how old are you guys
33 and 35 you guys are going to be you
guys are going to be
millionaires we hope so that's the goal
oh you will be you will be you are you
were on that path you guys can really
dream now you have nothing holding you
back that's thanks to you guys you guys
this program that you guys put out it's
it does work but you guys did the work
and that's the difference so fun all
right so tell us about the little one
let's get her in here what's her name
and how old Sawyer she's 16 months old
she has no idea how awesome her parents
are right now and her future that is so
fun look at sweet sawer that is going to
be is she going to freak out when you
guys scream we're not sure what we're
hoping she's going to scream too
so a couple things we're going to give
you a bundle here we've got the baby
steps millionaire book uh and we've got
of course Total Money Makeover for you
to gift to someone else and uh so that's
our gift to you guys so let's get to it
here we go we've got Chris and Amanda
from Rochester New York they paid off
49,000 in 11 months making 72,000 up to
90,000 let's hear your debt free screen
ready y 3 2 1 we're de
free
saw had a little delayed reaction but
now she's she's kicking and clapping and
she's excited that's what this is all
about Jade a legacy changing your family
tree and we just got to hear another
story don't move more Ramsey show coming
[Music]
up hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
[Applause]
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is alongside and we
are here for youle 8825 5225 so you got
money questions of course we're here for
you uh how about something that's
related to your money and that's your
work are you bored out of your skull are
you burned out are you getting
overlooked want to start something on
the side work for yourself any work
related questions uh I'm the work
personality if you will here on the
Ramsay network and on the Ramsey Show so
excited to have all of you with us 8825
5225 let's go to Devin in Kansas City
Devin how can we help hey guys how you
guys doing good what's going on hey so
should me and my wife increase our house
rent payment when we will have just paid
off our debt and I can get into that
more if you'd like yeah tell us so you
just paid off all the debt in baby step
2 is that what I'm understanding so we
will about the time that we have our
contract renewal um so in about March
February March we're expected to pay off
uh the rest of our debt and right about
then is when we're supposed to sign a
new lease for our uh rental but we're
wanting to upgrade in house size um
because we've just added uh to our
family recently tell me about that tell
me about that how many people in the
family have just been added so we only
have three right now so me my wife and
then a four-month-old um but we're
wanting to expand eventually so we're
trying to find a balance
between um rent payment is going to be
much higher but we're also wanting to
save for a house and also baby we're
trying to figure out how to bounce it
out all right we're gonna jump in okay
so it's you and mama and baby yes okay
and and what are you living in now give
me square footage or bedrooms just tell
me what the size of your current
apartment is
or house so right now we we run a house
that's a single um single layer 950
square foot about uh three bed one bath
one car garage we're wanting to try and
get you know two car garage maybe a
basement if we can um just just a little
bit more room we were blessed with a
bunch of um House Gifts when we got
married and whatnot and got way too much
stuff for our tiny little house so um
and I know these are all luxuries and
whatnot um so we're just trying you pay
for that we pay 1,25 right now a month
which is really good and if you were to
upgrade what would you be paying it'd
probably be more around
1,400 so okay so we're going up 300 and
some odd dollars um I'm not worried
about that Jade I was worried he was GNA
say it was closer to 2,000 I was too no
no no I'm not that crazy I mean here's I
don't think you need to move I think you
got a stuff problem I would stay I would
stay too because the big you agree with
us once in my life I was going to say
cuz I'm Mr like keep it tight and save
now for the house because like well
here's the here's what you have to ask
yourself like long term not even really
in the short term you're going to want
to buy a house you said yourself that
you guys are trying to save for it so
$400 or $375 uh dollar each month is a
lot of money it is and here's my thought
I'm like a four-month-old that's little
that's like a football that doesn't take
up much space and your wife she's not
pregnant yet still nine more months I
don't care how small it is you have
three bedrooms yeah yeah this this house
is just driving her nuts there's other
things our our neighbors aren't great
and I mean there's there's other things
that go along with we just don't like
the area
per We're not gonna get this deal
anywhere else well is that true I don't
know well from what I've been we we got
this house um in
2020 so it was kind of like right before
everything really jumped up so about the
same square footage is going about $3
$1400 right
now some areas and locally okay so I I W
to I hear what you're saying that
there's reasons and look at the end of
you're grown at the end of the day
you're going to get off this call and
you're going to do what you and your
wife think is best and I'm not mad at
that okay can we hold on let me jump in
because I want you to keep going but I
got to ask you how am I supposed to keep
going Ken cuz I'm going to ask a
question and let you keep going I'm not
taking over I'm just joking I know I
know I want you know I think this is a
happy wife happy life situation and you
are the resident wife in at the desk
today I she's not how does he handle
that he here's the problem and it's not
a problem it's the reality she has a
four-month-old so everything is going to
get on her nerves that's am I am I right
Deon you are right I I've been there
when you got a four-month old you notice
every everything's a problem you can't
even have the wrong look on your face
Devon cuz that's going to be a problem
too you know what I'm saying and so I
I've been there I think that it could
help them to just take a breath cuz
everything's new they have a
four-month-old everything's new and
everything's annoying y'all are still
tired Cranky Pants and we're not talking
about the
four-month-old you're about to get
yourself in trouble again no I'm talking
about him yeah oh him not the wife okay
okay I'm deferring I'm not g to I'm not
getting in the middle of that that's why
I brought you into that happy wife happy
life deal happy wife happy life does
have something do with it but I think
this is a question of what do you want
most or what do you want now happy and I
think well I it sounds like what they
want most is I'm just keeping it real I
would stay I would stay that's what I'm
saying but she wants to move so happy
wife would be her moving well I think we
got to bridge the gap we got to have a
conversation with Mama and have a
conversation with Mama and think about
ask yourself what do you want most do we
want to be able to buy the home that we
want sooner in Life or are we just do we
truly have to move because again and
Devon moving is expensive like folks
don't talk about that there's an expense
there there you're now uprooting your
life even more so it has the ability to
add even more stress because there's the
whole interim before you get to that
okay we're settled so you're about to
crank up the the volume on I got it you
know what I'm saying I think I got an
epiphany we'll see what this is this is
up for this is up for you and de take
you task on this and I'm fine with that
uh I think you have to sit down with
your wife and I think you got it
literally on paper yes write down what
the increase in rent would be and so
let's just say it's 350 a month increase
from what you are cuz you you've given
us that range and you write 350 time 12
equals and there's there's your first
year and you just lay the numbers out
and go if we were to save this money for
a
house um we can get there by such you
got to cast Vision you can't just tell
her to hey babe try to get through it
because to your point she's tired I love
that and I'll add one I'll add one more
to it once you get that number you need
to then run that back and go how many
hours of work is that because if we're
going to replace this income it means us
working right if you're going to say hey
not only are we going to ratchet up our
rent and it's going to cost us I don't
know $20,000 over the course $10,000
over the course of the year now what
does that look like us working to
replace that money it's a great call
right and now
you see what it is so I I like this
conversation Deon I like that you guys
are thinking about it I love that you
called in the show yeah thanks for
calling listen listen young couples if I
could say anything about this it's be
patient think about the long term I'd
suffer a little early on I would too to
get to the right house in the right
place yeah I just would I mean you're
supposed to be I mean Dave says it and I
love how I love the analogy renting is
camping it's camping you know and if you
get too hung up and you turn it into
glamping then you're kind of defeating
the purpose because it's it's a
short-term solution like it's just it's
a short-term solution while you're
getting yourself together until you can
buy because ultimately that's the goal
and I will say this I have three kids I
mean there is a day coming for a lot of
young couples if you have that many kids
where you need more space sure and and
there's a whole lot more expenses come
in your way I would be like if it need
Ken you don't need it okay roll yeah
roll it back on the need oh you're
talking about what I said yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah we were in a smaller house
when we grew up as kids you know we were
living in small houses oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah but I'm talking about like if
you're in a little teeny house like that
then you need multiple bedrooms and
bathrooms and all that kind of stuff
that that does get to that point
eventually yes but I still say the word
need is you do want more than one
bathroom yeah well when you have a
teenage daughter and two teenage boys
they can't all share the the same
bathroom that's true that's what I'm
talking about that's what the Coleman
were dealing with had to do it look let
me tell you we did it before they got to
middle school cuz that was not a
sustainable situation at one point we
lived in a duplex it was me my mom my
brother and me and my older brother that
would come home from college one
bathroom Ken I admire that I don't that
was tough times I get it but I I get it
but I'm saying I know you can do it
that's the whole point so Hey listen
there's coming a time where you got to
spend money on stuff if you don't have
to and the baby little don't hey good
hour Jade thank you so much James
Charles and all the guys and the gals in
the booth keeping us on the air don't
move more Amy show coming
[Music]
up
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show where
we help you win in your life with your
money your work and your relationships
the phone number for you and your
question is
8825 5225 8825 5225 I'm Kim Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me and uh we love being
here for you and your questions by the
way the Ramsey Show annual listener
survey is live we want to know what are
your favorite parts of the show what do
you want more of what do you want less
of what do you what topics do you want
us to cover uh all these things we want
to know how to serve you best there's
two ways to participate you can text the
word survey to 3378 9 that's survey text
that word to 3 3789 or visit ramseys
solutions.com survey ramsy solutions.com
survey sign up today and you will be
entered to win a $500 gift card just for
telling us what you think so be nice to
Jade and I please well speaking of
survey Ken uh I have surveyed my
comments on social media and we saw that
people wanted to hear more about the
baby steps and so we post I just the
team and I posted a video explaining
just briefly explaining baby steps one
two three and four and it went bananas
and so I thought to myself it brought in
a lot it brought in like 30 or 40,000
new folks all new to Ramsay and I
thought it would be good to go through
and really explain what we mean when we
talk about baby steps one just a
fundamental Simplicity of that video and
the plan went bananas on on Instagram
yeah y'all showed up well it probably
wasn't you guys it was new folks so just
when I think that everybody knows the
baby steps there's still people who
don't know what it is and that's great
let's do that so this is great so if
you're new to the show we have seven
baby steps and we're going to walk
through the first three and some of the
general questions around them so I'm
going to tee you up you good with that
yeah rapid fire so baby step one is we
want people to put
$1,000 in a savings account for your
garden variety basic emergency so the
question begs why
$11,000 is $11,000 enough no $1,000 is
not enough and it's not intended to be
enough hear me loud and clear this is
just temporary at the end of the day if
you have $1,000 saved as an as an
American you are ahead of the pack
because
56% the majority of Americans could not
cover $1,000 emergency without using
debt so if you have that you're ahead of
the game 36% of Americans have Z saved
so you're ahead of the game there as
well so yes $11,000 it's not enough but
it's enough to get you going
and so you're paying off your debt
quickly and then later on you'll stock
it up and you can do it quicker than you
probably think what do you think what do
you think is a rule of thumb on how
quickly you can assemble
$1,000 from nothing average person gets
it done in 30 days because you're going
ham you're selling stuff you're working
extra hours you are just literally
pulling from everywhere you can to get
this ham yeah go and ham sandwich I've
never heard of that before if I say that
will that be will that be cooler your
sons will probably be like who do you
know
well they know I know you so they'll
clearly think it's you okay good I'm
going to use that one this week it's
going to get some eye rolls ham Sal at
the house ham but I just say that just
ham yeah that's all I say you're going
ham yeah all right see now I'm learning
along with the audience and everybody
enjoys that okay now so where do they
keep it I said in a savings account that
is separate from checking why do we say
that well because a you get tempted by
it some people are more tempted by that
than others I'm a very I see money and
I'm like how can I spend it so keeping
it in a separate account I even like
putting it in another bank like an
online bank I've mentioned Ally before
we don't sponsor them in any way but I
love that by the way this account we're
not putting like debit cards and things
like that attached to it because it's an
emergency fund we don't want to have
easily accessible access to it right so
high yield savings account um if you can
oh I'm sorry you know what we're just
talking about baby stuff when you don't
have to put in a high yield savings
account you can just sock it away you
know put it in your sock drawer put it
in your normal savings account that's
fine sock drawer look where I come from
you don't really mean that do you $1,000
in a pair of socks well it depends on
what neighborhood you live in okay all
right I'm going to leave put in the bank
put it in a savings account now I think
we got to get to this what qualifies as
an emergency that we're going to
actually get into the Thousand hardly
anything that's hardly anything
qualifies for an emergency number one it
needs to be completely unexpected all
right cuz some of y'all are like oh well
you know Christmas is coming around the
corner no completely unexpected it has
to be completely
necessary that's and it has to be urgent
all right Qui real quick on this one why
wouldn't baby step three which is a 3 to
six Monon emergency fund why wouldn't
that be the first baby step just to kind
of ease our pain and our fear why would
we not do that well let's take a look I
mean we already said the stat most
people don't have anything saved and the
reason they don't have anything saved is
because all of their money is going out
of the door debt payments so it's hard
to have the money in your budget when
you've got a bunch of debt to Stack Up 3
to six months of expenses and most folks
give up or they keep dipping in and
spending it right there you go so all
right baby step two which is we say pay
off all of your debts and it's very
specific in baby steps too Jade we say
pay the smallest debt first then move up
if you will so smallest to largest why
do we recommend that yeah because we
want you to win and a lot of times that
smallest debt right is just a $200
Capital One card or a, 1500 deal you
know that you have with a credit card
company or a little private loan when
you pay that off you feel that win and
it's like it just excites your brain and
you're like you know what I can do this
and so you pay that one off and you have
the extra money freed up and you're able
to throw it to the smallest debt after
that and you get that momentum and you
get to experience those wins and it does
work what's the average amount of time
that we find it takes people to pay off
debt in baby step two if they're going
after it two years or less two years or
less wow fantastic years or less that's
nothing it really isn't in the grand
scheme of things and I want to point out
here is as the guy who's always focused
on work let me tell you something you
got to work work work every debt free
scream I have ever sat in on yeah we
have seen their income go up yeah and
the more income you make whether it's
multiple side hustles two full-time jobs
whatever your scenario is the way to get
out of the baby steps faster is to
increase your income go work but Ken
break that down cuz for some people it's
the core income and some folks just need
a side hustle that's exactly right if we
can't increase it via our core career so
if we can't get an extra hours if you
will or overtime within that we're going
to go work multiple other jobs working
weekends we're working 80 90 hours a
week depending on how intense our debt
situation is all right that takes us to
baby step three once we pay off all of
the debt how do we determine if we want
to go three months four months five
months or six months cuz Dave has given
us the range three to months of expenses
it's all about stability so if you are a
two inome household and you both have
really solid jobs and you're both
healthy three months is probably fine if
you're a single mom and you know you are
a server at a restaurant or you you know
have some volatility in your work you
probably want to lean towards 6 months
so we're looking at how many incomes are
coming in uh whether you're um married
or single like maybe you're single but
you've got like multiple income sources
maybe 3 months is okay look at your
health these are the things that we're
looking at and it doesn't have to be 3
to 6 months of your full budget we're
talking about what it takes for your
household to survive this is be bones
budget so do we keep it in that high
yield savings or do we invest it yeah
this is not going in the sock drawer
we're putting it in a high yield savings
account we are not investing this money
because if something happens you need to
be able to get to it so do not invest
your savings account there it is folks
baby steps 1 through three that's why we
teach it that way and don't forget go
get some work
with some experience and skill set that
you have to increase your income all
right good stuff way to go Jade hey
quick break got to pay some bills even
we have to pay the bills and we'll be
right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is with me the
phone number is tri8 825 5225 8 825 52
225 time for our question of the day
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services once the kids are back in
school it's hard to find time for Home
Maintenance but neighborly is your
source for home repair experts like
Precision Door Service or drier vent
wizard incidentally that was one of my
nicknames in high school dryer vent
wizard little side hustle that I
developed to make a little extra gas
money okay and I uh it was
self-proclaimed okay Ken could not be
backed up but uh nonetheless uh download
the neighborly app today to be ready For
All Seasons all right today's question
comes from Brian in Oregon he says I'm
22 years old I'm married with two kids
dang and I'm going to school for
engineering I work around 30 to 35 hours
a week at my family's flooring business
and it pays the bills but it won't get
me the engineering experience that an
internship would on the flip side an
internship wouldn't cover the bills so
my question is is it worth going into
debt so that so I can take an internship
to build experience for engineering down
the road no and it's it's also a false
narrative Brian you don't have to have
an
internship to get entrylevel experience
for engineering you're going to school
for
engineering so stay in school finish the
engineering and what
is entry level for someone who gets an
engineering degree the answer is you
know I don't know maybe you don't know
but you can find find out but there is
entry-level engineering jobs that's
where you're going to have to start yeah
so we're not going into debt to go get
an internship heck no you want to get
job placement through the school that
you're getting the engineering degree
and at least and then and then apply the
proximity principle I wrote an entire
book on one little thought it just says
this in order to do what Brian wants to
do insert blank type of engineering got
to be around people that are doing it
and in places where it is happening so
while you're in school raising those
babies working 30 35 hours you're also
on weekends and nights having coffee
having lunch spending time with
Engineers who are way ahead of you uh in
this in this world and they're going to
tell you their thoughts on how you get
place and how you get in and if you do
it with a spirit of humility and hunger
there might just be some of those guys
and gals that you meet with who will
open up a door for you so uh no to uh a
loan in order to do an internship no to
credit cards in order to do the
internship you don't need the internship
what you need is are connections Ken let
me let me ask you about something so you
just said you know get around these
folks hopefully they will put you on and
you know give you opportunity yeah let's
talk a little bit about
gatekeeping yeah love it and this idea
of I see this all the time especially
with social media influencers people who
start their own business and they feel
like they've uh
figured something out and they're afraid
to share it because they're afraid if
they share it what they'll give up their
piece of the pie and then that's you
know what I'm saying like what what are
your thoughts on yeah well there your
thoughts on that yeah there are some
people that are going to be very very
scarcity focused I don't want to help
you you could be competition I don't
want to use some favor you know by
connecting a young Ken Coleman to this
person I don't want to do that I had
people do that they just they don't want
to use whatever capital is there to say
hey would you connect with this young
guy and have lunch with him or whatever
do we take it personal is is it personal
no you can't take it personal no it's
actually about them they really do have
you know Michael eer was just in town
this week they have a scarcity mindset
everything for them is I've limited this
limited that and I'm not going to use my
relationship Capital to call somebody up
and go will you meet with so and so and
so to your point of opening Gates um
you're gonna have some people that
aren't willing to do it they'll either
say no or they will ghost you and that's
unfortunate but you can't take it
personally you just have to go for
whatever reason it's about them they
don't feel comfortable and that's all
you can do and then you go to people who
are comfortable and I've always been
that person well I mean but as okay as
the person who is in need like in want
of exposure or whatever how do you where
do you draw the line because there's
been times where people have been like
hey just just contact so and so and I'm
like like I can't they're further along
than me like I don't want to sound like
I'm using my relation you know I don't
want to use our relationships try to get
something from them like how do you well
I've gotten I've had to I get that and
I've had to get comfortable with what I
think is the most underused question in
the world and that's will you help me uh
it doesn't need to be smarmy it
shouldn't be a too big of an ask it
should be a basic ask but I will tell
you I've reached out to people on social
to do an interview or hey I'd love to
touch Bas to do of this and nothing and
so I go all right yeah I'm moving on but
I mean like interview that's something
that has the ability to benefit both
parties yeah but still yeah they they'll
ghost you they don't think you're a big
enough deal who knows what they're
thinking I can't fill in that Gap that
cares an unhealthy narrative so I just
go all right it's not it's not meant to
be I I interviewed solidad O'Brien you
remember do you know her name solad
longtime journalist and I interviewed
her for my first book one question and I
asked her about you know because she had
she had made her way into media and I
asked her she Dropped a Bomb on Me I
said how do you deal with rejection and
she said I turn I learned how to turn no
into not now or not
here and that to is to this day is one
of the best pieces of advice I've ever
heard anybody give me that's interesting
so you just got to go cuz no is very
final yeah and no's very personal well
let me add you just said no to me right
you said no to me I think I'm pretty
good guy you know whatever and it's very
personal very final let me add one to
that because I just read something that
said no simply means I need more
information
I'm a I I have a little bit of fear and
I need a little bit more
information what do you think I think
that's fair interesting but but but
point I think that's true but in a
situation where you want a job and you
get a
no they may needed more information but
you're not going to get chance to give
it to them so so now so I think that's
probably squares but but the point is
it's not why they said no the point now
is is what do I do with no and I think
for those of us who hear the no we've
got to now turn that into not yet yet
not here and and realize every know that
I get even if I'm moving forward every
no is getting me closer to the yes
that's right that's what word so I I
just think that that's now by the way
it's easy for me to say that now with
some gust though right but I had to eat
eat dust and eat dirt and eat nose and
all that just along the way I mean I had
a guy tell me once you know you you
don't have enough talent to make in a
top 10 media market so you you shouldn't
even be trying this
and and I believed him yeah I for a
while you have too you got some
rejection stories oh yeah the rejection
is real but I mean it is it's all about
how you use it as fuel and you can't let
it stop you from asking again or
continuing to make those those movements
forward so yeah absolutely true triple 8
825 5225 one thing I want to talk about
really quick this is very important uh
we we talk a lot about budgeting yes and
how if you're going to win with money
there is no is this too strong of a
statement you cannot win with money if
you don't know where your money is that
is not too strong all right so budgeting
is a big deal and every dollar is our
budgeting tool it is absolutely
fantastic we're very proud of it um it
is an amazing tool we can connect it to
your bank account if you want to go that
far and to go along with encouraging you
to budget we've got an awesome thing
coming up Jade and you're a part of this
along with Rachel Cruz and you're
partnering with every dollar what's
going on that's right so on Monday the
30th talking about October 30th we are
hosting one uh webinar a budgeting
webinar now what Ken was saying is this
is a series I'm hosting them George
camel is hosting them Rachel Cruz is
hosting them uh but if you want to do a
webinar with me that's totally free it's
this coming Monday October 30th the
webinar is during your lunch hour during
your lunch break it starts here at 11:30
Central it's free guys it's free to sign
up I'm giving you an hour of my time
totally free and if you really want to
follow along go ahead and download an
every dooll budget you can you can
download that for free and you can
follow along with us we're going to tell
you how to use this thing because this
is how you win these are the tools that
you need in your tool box in order to
win with money and every dollar is like
like a good like power drill it's like a
sledgehammer man like this is what you
need where do they go they go to
everydollar.com budgeting to sign up all
right give me a little sing us out here
with a little this is how we
this is how we do it oh I wish I could
do that I can't I know it why did you
choose Montel Jordan guys cuz you said
this is how we do it oh I was I'm
listening I'm picking up on what you're
laying down isn't that what the kids say
I don't know what's happening folks I'm
going to take us a commercial break and
learn how to talk cool this is the Ry
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw join me and we are
here for you America
8825 5225 that's
5225 and we've got a great studio
audience here with us as we do most days
great to see all those folks out in the
lobby and then uh in the lobby but on
the debt free stage is Gabriel and
Ariana how are you two good and you guys
great good did I say your name right yes
okay lovely I didn't want to start off
on the wrong foot did great oh well
thank you and you guys are from Chicago
Chicago the windy city yes fantastic and
what brings you down here a de free
scream I'm guessing yes oh yeah all
right let's get the numbers how much
debt did you pay off 200 and hold on let
me get my cheat sheat here there it is
no worries we can wait uh 20 and is it
on
85,3 wow holy cow and how long did that
take 71 months W 71 months and tell us
the range of inome during that time
150,000 when we began to about 170 now
but it it did fluctuate a lot in in
between sure what do you guys do uh I'm
a firefighter oh thank you for that
great service that's great and um I work
for Chicago Public Schools okay good and
any overtime in there I'm guessing is
that what some of that is oh yeah uh
yeah well prior to uh becoming a
firefighter I used to uh um be partners
in a construction company mhm so uh that
was part of like the journey and also
the income fluctu fluctuation that she
was mentioning okay yeah so all right
great what kind of debt was this um so
we had uh
30 $
35,320 remaining was for our mortgage we
off our hey sh I was wondering I is
wondering that's amazing yeah wow you
know Dave says we're looking at weird
people he likes to say that I don't
think you guys look weird but I but uh I
get the point look a paid off house in
Chicago that's weird come on now I get
it so what happened almost six years ago
for you guys to take this journey yeah
one of our good friends uh at the church
we used to attend uh was hosting the
financial peace class and uh we decided
to to take to take it and uh our life
just Chang from that point forward wow
okay give me a little bit more yeah so
so you know what was going on to where
you go all right cuz the way you said
that it was kind of like we just wed on
in there yeah so um our very good friend
like like he said um they were giving
these classes and they were people that
we trusted and then and they were also
following the Ramsey plan and they were
very good with their money and um we
didn't really argue about money but at
the end of every month we'd be like we
make good money where is it going to um
so the class really just helped us to
change our lives and to really buckle
down and to make our money work for us
wow let me ask you kind of a um inverse
question yeah out of what you learned in
that class what did you push back on the
most um probably the like the budgeting
was hard for us cuz we didn't we didn't
budget like like she mentioned kind of
at the end of the month we just kind of
be like what happened with all the money
you both that was probably the hardest
part and then um when he was working in
the construction business um the income
fluctuated so much that it was very hard
to budget um but we we're here so we
made it you did it so uh what did you
what was the first debt that you took on
I'm just curious um the first debt that
we took on was um right after the class
we did uh my student loans um we had
like 4,000 and credit cards and then we
had a $112,000 um car loan and that's
the first thing we did and then after
that um we sold our house and um we made
a profit of a little bit over $86,000 so
we used that to put um 20% down on on a
new property and we bought the ugliest
house on the black wow um and um yeah we
use the rest we cash flowed uh
$250,000 in a home renovation
wow wow so that's not including so it's
no it's no longer the ugliest house on
the Block No No Yeah that's beautiful
wow that's so smart so what would you
say is the key to getting out of debt uh
being on the same page and uh just um
supporting one another getting uh you
know having a a core of people also that
are supporting you like our family was
very supportive yeah um our close
friends uh were very supportive also and
being content um and uh just being okay
with delayed gratification and knowing
that um while we did make good money on
paper at the end of the day if we didn't
um take these steps then we were not
really going to be able to enjoy it at
the end of the day that's right well you
don't have a payment in the world no
what happens next um we're just saving
for our next uh investment I feel like
we're still you got to do something to
celebrate I feel like we're still on the
ramsy plan uh we're so deep in right now
I feel like it's so normal why not
continue until we get you know our next
investment I'm giving you homework this
is baby step 7B is you need to go and do
something fun yeah there is a cruise in
our future we don't know when but oh
there you go we also added two kids
while we were in the process too so C So
when you say investment what do you mean
we want to have an investment property
at some point um yeah I'm still working
we have uh three kids and it's so funny
cuz a lot of people say oh you sold your
you paid your house sorry um that means
that you don't have to work and I don't
feel like that's the case I feel like we
really we're starting over we have a
fresh um start yeah and it doesn't end
here no we still have goals and we still
have aspirations and what is your house
worth I say about like 700,000 now boy
and what what do you guys have in
retirement um we had to kind of slow
that down while we doing I know we
shouldn't have yeah like 100,000 okay
and we're both vested in our pensions
okay so you guys are you guys are just
steps from being
millionaires net worth and you guys are
you guys are off and running yeah we're
excited you should be yeah and um
another part of our journey was um there
was one point where we were on one
income and it was because we had been
following the baby steps that it was
okay and this had been our goal when we
when we purchased the house we said
we're going to pay off the house in 5
years and because we had been on the the
baby steps plan and we had uh money in
uh in our um sa emergency funds it
didn't derail us from our plan and we
finished exactly when we said wow that's
amazing you two are such an inspiration
for so many people that are watching and
listening today and we'll see the story
in the days ahead so one of the things
we want to do for you is we've got a
little bundle here for you we're going
to give you uh Dave's latest book baby
steps millionaires cuz you guys are
really really close to that and so
that's yours and then we're going to
give you a copy of The Total Money
Makeover to gift to somebody else to pay
this whole idea forward and so that is
our gift to you all right let's get the
kids up real quick who do you have with
us tell us their names and ages um we
have Eliana valz she's five months yeah
okay and then we have um Daniel and
Nathaniel they're um they're outside oh
they're outside they're making their way
in they're making their way in okay and
how old are they how old are the boys um
Daniel is seven okay and uh Nathaniel is
two he is two wow older one that's not
with us right now he's uh had some
important things going on with school so
he wasn't able to make the tree W you
guys Chang your family tree that's
amazing Daniel hey Daniel he'll be here
one day for his debt that's right he
hopefully no debt but his house paid off
has he been practicing the scream the
boys yes okay look at this all right
cuties all right here we go all right
gang we ready to go we've got Gabriel
Ariana Daniel Nathaniel and Eliana from
Chicago Illinois they paid off
$285,000 in 71 months including their
house making 150 all the way up to
$170,000 all right gang let's hear a
windy city debt-free scream make it loud
ready 3 2 1 we're de
[Music]
free yeah I love it fantastic the baby's
going why is everyone screaming that's
my
role beautiful you know Jade thoughts on
that that lovely family and an
unbelievable future look don't tell me
y'all can't do it they did it in the
city of shy Town yeah unbeli unbel story
wow this is what it's all about folks
you can do it and we are here to help
don't move more Amy show coming
up
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw is alongside
8825 5225 our scripture of the day comes
from 1 Corinthians
13:6 and 7 love does not Delight in evil
but rejoices with the truth it always
protects always trusts always hopes
always perseveres our quote of the day
from none other than the king or maybe
the Kang depending on where you're from
Elvis Presley the truth is like the sun
you could shut it out for a time but it
ain't going
away I like that the king of rock and
roll you know what I mean you know what
I'm saying uh-huh
oh uh boy we've lost control James is
about ready to turn our mics off let's
go to Alex who joins us in Los Angeles
Alex how can we help hey Ken hey Jade
hope you guys are well we are we're
having too much fun what's going on all
right I need some help um my husband and
I have a car loan it is our last debt
other than our mortgage um it's about
$39,000 left on the car um it's not our
only car but I also have um about 50 a
little over $50,000 in some stock that I
have with my company um from like our
stock purchase program and I'm wondering
if it would be a good move to sell the
stock and pay off the car one two three
yes yes yes even if it's at a
loss yes to sell the stock at a loss
because the Market's down is that what
you're saying yes yeah I mean yes you
can't control that it could keep going
down exactly and you need to get out of
debt and the fact of the matter is we're
cleaning up part of getting out of debt
is is cleaning up not just debt but but
poor financial choices in general
and not to say I mean look you invested
your money in stocks it's not
necessarily the first place you want to
go to make an investment so we're we're
kind of clearing the table here and
resetting it the right way and not only
is that paying off debt but it's also
making sure that your money is invested
in the right way and so in this case
yeah I would totally clear out those
stocks and I would pay off this car and
you'd be debt free as soon as that money
that cash clears how good is that going
to feel Alex allow yourself to go there
right now let's just assume we've just
paid it off you're on the phone with
with the uh creditors right now we said
okay Alex the car is paid off in some
weird voice like that how would that
feel oh my gosh I just took like a a big
breath
out okay see we just we just role played
right into that this is the Nob brainer
of the century love it okay Hey listen
you got to look at this stock as free
money how often do we get free money
yeah yeah I guess I'm just worried
because that's kind of you know we treat
it as we don't look at it and it's just
kind of a quote unquote emergency fund I
know it's not in the right place but
that's kind of our back happen you know
what this is this is the get out of debt
and change your life forever fund yeah
it is okay I I just curious what what at
the high point or you know you said it's
at a loss what did you start
with um it was probably closer to you
know 65 that's what you put that's what
you put in to
start uh yeah it it's been growing over
the last couple years so you know when I
was buying it was at a higher you know
it was it was uh lower and then it I
think it went up to my question is what
was your initial investment like where
did you start like what have you put
into
it oh um not not know not do you see
what I'm saying like you can look at and
say at one point it was 65,000 and now
it's only 50 but depending on what you
put in it you may have still do you see
what I'm saying over the life of it you
still may come out may have come out on
top if you know what you what your basis
is in it but anyway oh I need to look at
it but it sounds like I'm just gonna
sell it anday yes stop we don't want to
think about it we just want to do it you
know there will be some left in it after
I you know I still have some money in
there should I sell it all and then
reinvest with a leftover into something
else uh CH just make sure you set aside
some for taxes because there's probably
going to be some taxes on that because
it's adding to your your income so keep
some aside and then whatever's there I'd
probably throw it in the emergency fund
or you can throw it at your next baby
step yeah oh okay I needed you guys to
tell me this so thank you so much yes
you're going to be free girl that's F
that car and boy that car is going to
feel better it's going to run better
going to look better when it's paid off
so that's exciting stuff yeah very
excited don't overthink it yeah just
take care of this today like today
you're you're on you're in La you still
got time to make this happen all right
let's go to Clarice in Tampa Clarice how
can we help I knew you were going to do
sorry I had to you just freaked me out
Clarice I'm sorry for my colleague and
her scary greeting
I know you are I know you are
Clarice how can we help so my question
is um I have some money saved up and I
recently learned about tax leans and
deeds so I want to know if I should use
that money to get into thatt or if I
should pay off um my debt I'm sorry I
misheard you you said you just learned
about what tax leans and deeds okay tax
leans and deeds yeah okay to get into
like real estate okay so should I use my
like the money to get the properties or
should I pay off my debt we're going to
pay off your
debt we're going to pay off your debt uh
because I'm guessing you want to get
these properties to to cash flow to you
know this whole thing yeah um that's big
right now it's big on social media
everybody's like this is the way that
you can get in the into real estate want
to get out of my career honestly well I
can help you with that without without
getting yourself into more trouble you
need to pay off debt and we can get you
on the right path yeah what are you
doing and what do you want to
do um well I'm a nurse and um my husband
and I were wanting to start a family in
like two years he um when he comes home
and so uh I want just more free time you
know free time to be home with my
children inste of have to go clock in at
the hospital sure how much money do you
make right now as a nurse um I made 130
okay okay bring home and that's really
good and so your big reason for getting
out is more free time is that what I
heard yes yes how much debt do you
have um besides our house um I have
14,000 on my car and 35 um for student
loans what about your
husband my husband has uh no debt he's
um military mhm and his car is paid off
and what's his
income uh he makes about 60 Grand is he
deployed right now he is okay because he
you said two years is he deployed for
the next two years no no he comes home
next year but next year that's the time
frame they we're planning on starting a
family right and and so right now I
understand you want free time
but you need to pay off debt you need to
you know you can't just go from uh from
your income to his income he's not going
to be thrilled with that right away is
he uh no not at all well here's the
thing though so why don't we just do
some nursing that's maybe a little bit
different rhythm in a different place
you got some
options I do and I'm trying to do that
while he's gone while I have the time
but I'm just I just really want to get
out of it so I was like if I can get a
property and like use the money that I
have in my you're creating more you're
creting more problems to solve a problem
that's actually pretty easy to solve
number one is you guys make $190,000 a
year that's a great income and you got
$50,000 $49,000 of debt right you can
knock that out so fast you don't have
kids yet you gu like if you went on a
barebones budget you would be out of
debt in less than a year less than a
year if you guys decided hey instead of
living on 190 this year we're living on
140 140 that's still double the average
average income more than double the
average income so it just takes you guys
quickly going you know what let's knock
this thing out let's be out of Deb in 8
months and nine months and then when
you're out of debt you suddenly have
freedom You go Okay now what's the next
conversation if we have kids and we
decide that I want to be a stay-at-home
mom we have to decide okay are we
willing to live a lifestyle on 60 maybe
his incup goes up slightly I don't know
what his career trajectory is but can we
live a lifestyle on 60,000
and if not maybe that looks like okay is
there something that you can do
part-time to where maybe if you're not
bringing in 130 anymore but could you
bring in another 60 could you bring in
another
$50,000 and so I think that there's a
lot of conversations and a lot of ways
to make this work for you Clarice but
I'm telling you what is not an option
and please cross it off your list use a
black Sharpie to where you can't even
see through it we're not going to buy
real estate and go deeper into debt
hoping that there's an opportunity to
cash flow or rent and we're certainly
not going to do it on multiple
properties trust and believe that's a
terrible idea great advice Jay thank you
for the call Clarice and to the rest of
you thank you for joining us here on the
Ramsey Show thanks to our fearless
leader James Charles hey we'll be back
before you know it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
m